okay let's start the singing session
with a gesture brownie as the first
speaker a first thanks to watch shop
organizers for inviting me so I want to
talk about some new work that I've done
with my collaborator Eric bleh at
University of Waterloo this is about
both strong direct sub and randomized
career complexity I think there's a I
like it as a it's I feel like it's a
nice bag of little interesting things so
hopefully you will also find something
interesting in this talk so I want to
start by just recapping direct some kind
of problems so in grad school Amit
always kind of described this in terms
of peeling potatoes so you've you've got
some function you want to compute how
much resources does it cost to compute K
times these resources so a direct sum
theorem might say that computing K
copies requires K times the resources
related is direct product if you've got
maybe some randomized computation model
with error and you want to compute K
copies with like somewhat less than K
times resources then a direct product
theorem might say that the success
probability goes down exponentially with
the number of things you're trying to
compute so I guess our starting point is
a strong direct sum result and this is
related to direct sum so in a
computational model where you're
computing K copies and maybe it's
randomness and with error the naive
thing does that actually doesn't cost
just K times the resources it costs more
the very naive thing to do is is just
compute each one with error say epsilon
over K and then take a Union bound over
that so I'm going to call a strong
direct sound theorem is a result that
says computing K copies requires a
synthetically more than K times to
resources pops you're saying the error
is the same
as in that's correct yeah so I want
computing K copies output in all K of
them I want I want to have overall error
epsilon and the naive solution is to
compute each one individually with with
probability epsilon over K and then you
can bound over everything so the
question is if I if I want out answers
to all K of them with overall error some
reasonable epsilon do I actually have to
compute everything with low error okay
so we study this in the model of
randomized query complexity we've got a
little bit of a twist so we're allowing
two ports here so if you haven't seen
randomized Craig complexity before maybe
you want to compute some function on a n
bit string decision tree is a labeled
binary tree you start at the root you
probe that particular bit and you go
left or right depending on the value of
that bit at the end you output some
answer and we're gonna allow you to also
abort so the cost for a deterministic
algorithm a deterministic decision tree
is just the length of the longest path
down to the root we'll be looking in the
randomized setting the I guess easiest
way to go from deterministic term
analyzers you've just got a probability
distribution over deterministic trees
but for the most part in this talk I'm
going to view randomized query algorithm
it's just a standard algorithm where I'm
being charged for the inputs on probing
so most of you haven't seen query
complexity or communication complexity I
guess there's a distribution version and
a randomized version and you can do
minimax to show that these two are
related
so if just notationally if I ever see on
the slide you Delta Epsilon he was
always the number of queries Delta
always the abort probability Epsilon
always the error probability so
two quick facts there's a minimax
version the abort and error
probabilities are tweaked because we're
we're minimax in over two different
measures and standard error reduction
you can repeat things T times this this
is a little bit better than you might
think because you can drive down the
abort and error probability at the same
time so just to avoid a notational
overload I'm typically gonna be stating
results either distributionally or for
the randomized version whichever one is
more convenient for this particular
result and I'm gonna leave it to you to
connect the dots using minimax their
error reduction okay so there are a lot
of related works to this I'm gonna give
you the white meat here this strong
direct sum result has been studied in
the context of interactive information
compare T complexity by Gregory and
David and Marko Molinaro so they have a
nice result for interactive information
complexity you get nice application for
scheming is sketching Drucker gave a
direct product theorem and there have
also been some very nice recently
randomized complexity separations by
Tony and and Troy and others in
particular was somewhat surprising to me
that the randomized query complexity of
zero error versus bounded error was was
not separated until two years ago three
years ago surprising to me so this is a
Drucker's main direct product theorem so
if you've got a t query algorithm with
success probability 1 minus epsilon then
any query algorithm that uses TK times
epsilon maybe with some constant has
exponentially small success probability
this epsilon is important it it needs to
be there and this starting point for our
research was an open problem of Drucker
which
what the query complexity would be if
you were allowed little Omega of T times
K queries so our main results are as
follows
we've got a strong direct some
distributional theorem in terms of it
errors with aborts so we show that to
compute F of K and epsilon error you
need to compute K times the resources of
computing one copy with error epsilon
over K but you're also allowed to have a
constant abort probability we also show
a function where the query complexity
scales would live 1 over epsilon this is
robust at having abort
so even if you're allowed to abort 50%
of the time the query complexity still
scales with log 1 over Epsilon and again
this is tight so than that you thing to
do drive down the error uses this log 1
over Epsilon so the two taken together
shows that there is a function with
optimal blow-up in the number of
resources ok like K is the best we can
do and I'm actually going to start with
a technical hook which I think is in
terms of technical tricks it's the most
interesting part of our paper so we
define this query resistant code it's a
mapping for some alphabet to n bit
strings such that you basically need to
query half the strings to find out
anything interesting about X so part of
the challenge from previous work from
getting that asymptotic elite type query
complexity bounds is that the lower
bounds were based on a the number of
cells you probed for a function which
had a large alphabet so this is how we
get rid of the loss factor there so I'm
gonna actually start the development
from the bottom of this slide and go up
so I'll show the query resistant codes
I'll show this function and show how we
get this large blow up and if there's
room anytime
do the strong direct some at the end
okay so let's see what a query resistant
code is so I'm gonna define Delta n
query is just a code of some alphabet
Sigma Sigma it's you can think of it as
a probabilistic encoding so I'm going to
take each letter in Sigma and I'm going
to map it to a distribution on n bit
strings we need the distributions to be
disjoint and we need them to partition
all the N bit strings and the technical
requirement here is that no matter what
bits of the encoding that you probe
information theoretically you learn
nothing about the original X which is to
say that these two distributions are
exactly the same no matter what bits you
probe and no matter what value you get
you got out of it okay it can be useful
also to talk about the decoding function
so because they partition these set of
all n bit strings you give me an N bit
string I'm going to give you the X which
is in the support of that distribution
and in our paper we have a construction
of an N over 2 query resistant code all
that technical details are not actually
ours where they're essentially under the
hood its KYT uniform distributions so
let's show how to use a query resistant
code so given any function on a large
alphabet you can describe a new function
that uses just bit probes in the natural
way so if I've got an array of n
different n bit strings I'm just going
to take each one of those in bit strings
decode it and then apply the original
function so the main hook here is it
doesn't matter what F and Sigma are if
you've got this query resistant code
then the number of cells you probe here
can be less than or equal to and over 2
time's the query complexity of the
larger function so if you flip that
around this says essentially you need to
do whatever you did for a lowercase F
but probe all the bits in each cell
every time you do it the construction is
quite simple so I'm gonna take my
algorithm for F and here's my algorithm
for a little F so exelon 3 xn is my
input for a little F I'm gonna apply my
query resistant code on each letter each
cell in my string and then I'm just
gonna emulate a so by the error
guarantees of this query algorithm a for
every single input we have error
probability at most Delta sorry Eric
abort probability at most Delta error
probability at most Epsilon
so this this this input that I'm feeding
into a is is now a distribution on
inputs for capital F but we get the same
error guarantees so the trick is how to
do this in a in a query efficient way
for a little F and all we're gonna do is
keep on sampling whatever this bit is
whichever bits this algorithm a probes
until we end up sampling half the bits
in one cell and then we sample the
original thing and then just move on
with our day so the fact that these two
distributions G of X and G of X prime
are equal condition on probing any and
he said abyss and whatever those values
they are let us do this efficiently so
we don't actually need to know what X I
is to do this initial sampling because
this conditional distribution is always
going to be the same up until some
barrier given by our query resistant
code and then once we get to that
barrier then we just probe the original
input and then keep going so every
single time we probe
a cell on our function f we don't do
that until after we probe and over to
bits for the original function so the
number of cells we probe is a 2 over N
factor what did we gain by this
reduction so I'm trying to show that in
here we're making kind of powerful
queries so we're not probing bits here
we're probing characters in our alphabet
which might be actually large so I care
about tight asymptotic bounds for bit
probes so I needed a construction which
kind of forced us to probe essentially
the entire contents of one cell
are there any other questions about this
algorithm
okay so in a in a second I'm going to
show you the function where we end up
getting tight asymptotic bounds on the
query complexity the way we actually
prove this is by going through a chain
of intermediate functions and all of our
actual reductions are randomized
reductions very similar to the flavor of
this so I'll give you the suite of
functions we actually look at the first
function is is super simple it's just
gap identity you've got an N bit string
you an output one if it's all zeros
output 0 if half the bits are 1 so in
the and Venus at all paper you use this
they use this as intuition for their
lower bound we're gonna make our lower
bound explicit and explicitly rely on
this so we can show that even with a
constant fraction of aborts the query
complexity this is log of 1 over Epsilon
up until Absalon gets to like 2 to the
minus and over 2 or approximately
so our next intermediate function I've
got a picture up here so your your
inputs an M by n grid of cells cells can
be black red or blue and there's a
promise that each column has a unique
cell that's not black and there's also a
promise that all of the non black cells
are either all red or half are red and
half are blue and you just want to
distinguish which one it is so we we can
do a reduction from gap ID to show that
the query complexity of blue red scales
by factor of M over deaf identity our
next function is this pointer function
it's on the board it was in both of the
previous query complexity papers so you
might have seen it before I I thought
this would make a terrible slide so I
wrote it on the board and and in
hindsight I think I've just transferred
them the measure of terribleness
over to white boards so the input again
here is an M by n grid but this time the
cells are really fat so there's a lot of
information in each cell in particular
each cell contains a value bit a back
pointer to a different cell and what I
call a tree pointer so there's gonna be
roughly root n different three pointers
and we want an output one if and only if
a series of conditions happens and I
want to emphasize that this is very very
similar in flavor to the previous work
so I'm not claiming originality here so
we want to output one if there's a
unique special column where the value of
every entry of all the cells in the
column is 1 and within that column
there's a unique special cell and all
the other cells in the unique special
column have null pointers on all their
pointers
and in all the other columns that are
not this special column there's going to
be at least one cell with value zero and
all of these cells are going to be
pointed to by a depth to tree so these
root end pointers are gonna go out to
route n different notes these are going
to go out to route n different nodes
total size of the tree is going to be
just n we require all the nodes in this
depth to tree to be one cell in each
column and again the value of all these
are going to be zero except for this
special element the root of this chain
and the last thing is for half of these
nodes off the special column all the
pointers are null and then for the other
half they point back to this special
cell
I think the intuition here is we're
embedding an instance of deaf identity
in here the trick is to how to figure
out how to find this special column
efficiently these back pointers are
going to help you do it
okay and the last function we've
essentially already done so once we have
pointer function we're just gonna slap
the query resistant code onto it and
that reduction is all are already done
generically okay so chaining together
all the theorems I listed here this is
going to give a lower bound of the
encoding function of n times M times log
1 over Epsilon and in the in Venus paper
they have an upper bound you can massage
it for us and it ends up being tight so
this encoding function is the the
function where we have asymptotic ly
tight query complexity on the bits are
there any questions at this point on
this function yeah so this is a total
function so pointer functions total it's
important that it's total this
separation between 0 and epsilon error
has been known for a long time for
partial functions so this is actually a
good point to point out so this pointer
function I haven't really fully
specified the input i've only specified
when you're supposed to output 1 and if
you ever get any violation in here
you're supposed to output 0 so these are
total function
okay so as I mentioned before and bein
us at all used a very similar pointer
function which is apparently based on
the original paper by Miss Pataki and
Watson
the main difference for them is that
they have just two pointers down so
there are three ends up being a log and
binary tree and they lose a log factor
because they call down the tree we have
a depth to tree so we lose a constant
factor so the ambience a tall paper in
their paper they they say that they take
intuition from deaf identity we make it
explicit here so I'm going to give you a
quick sketch lower bound for gap
identity I've got a hard distribution
which is based on Delta and epsilon so
with probability alpha which is you
should think of it as Delta if you think
of epsilon is small so with probability
alpha we've got on all zero string
otherwise it's a uniform string over the
yes inputs and I should mention at this
point that as far as I know this is the
first time people studied query
complexity with aborts and errors so we
don't have general techniques for
proving lower bounds when we have these
aborts in query complexity so the way we
ended up doing this just by this chain
of reductions one of the reasons why we
do that is because Jeff identity is so
simple and so restrictive that we can
actually prove a lower bound using
aborts so for a sake of contradiction
take an appropriate algorithm for gap
identity and I want to mention that
without loss of generality I can assume
that as soon as we see a 1 we know that
we're not the l0 string so there's no
reason to not just output 0 in the other
case so we can assume that every single
gap identity protocol is just a very
narrow
binary tree as soon as we see a one
we're gonna output zero use a different
color here
there's euros all the way down we can
get a lower bound because without loss
of generality we can assume the decision
tree looks like this and there's only
one node where we don't have the output
already fixed so based on the hard
distribution we can look at what happens
when we decide to abort here and what
happens when we decide to output zero
and what happens when we decide to
output one there's only three cases in
all three cases either the abort
probability is too large or the error
probability is too large and this
contradicts the guarantee of my
deterministic decision tree so that's it
for the gap ID identity lower bound all
the other reductions are gonna be only
slightly more complicated than this so
the next reduction I'm gonna connect gap
identity to blue red the only novelty
here is I'm gonna I'm gonna map every
input that's zero to a red cell every
input that's one to a blue cell and I'm
gonna randomize where I place these
cells in my blue red input and we do
have an increase in abort probability of
one over ten so we're gonna emulate the
algorithm for blue red based on this if
we ever have to probe an entry that's
not one of these colored cells my
emulator knows that it's supposed to be
a black entry so I'm just going to
return that without probing if it's a
colored entry we're gonna go query the
input bit again if it's zero we output
we say it's red if it's one we can say
it's blue we can also just stop the
emulation right now because we know that
we're in the no instance so the only
question is what happens when we run out
when we query too many cells and you
should expect us to query roughly n over
two cells and over two and this turns
out to be true so you can't query more
than seven q / M
this is a little bit technical but
hopefully not too hard so I'm going to
look at any column and note that because
the emulating algorithm placed this
colored entry uniformly no matter what
the blue red algorithm does the
probability that it find a colored entry
in my case query is exactly 1 divided by
the number of rows so if you look at any
leaf in this algorithm and count the
number of colored entries I find the
probability mass of reaching that leaf
is 1 over m to the T and so then we're
just gonna iterate calculate all the K
choose T possible cells that have
exactly T colored entries and there's
some telescopes and the overall
probability is 1 over 10 so we abort if
we probe too many sellers otherwise we
get the same error and abort guarantees
that we had before the last reduction
that we have here is connecting blue red
to the pointer function and this one I
think is a little bit subtle so any
black input any black cell I'm gonna map
to one with all bottom pointers any red
cell we're gonna map to 0 with all
bottom pointers and the emulating
algorithm doesn't know how to map the
blue cells so these blue cells
intuitively are gonna map into these
inputs with value 0 but back pointers to
this special cell and without knowing
exactly where the set of all the blue
entries are like we don't actually know
how to do this mapping but but the win
here is we don't need to because as soon
as we query a blue cell then we know
that we know what the output is so we're
gonna hop the emulation
so the only last piece here is we do get
a bump up in error and the only error
that happens so it note that if we're in
a no instance so sorry if we're in a yes
instance which means that all the
colored entries are red the emulating
algorithm can just emulate the entire
algorithm it knows how to do that
so the abort and error probability are
not going to jump up at all the only
question is what happens when I'm half
red and half blue and I'm going to
calculate an upper bound on the error
that this emulating algorithm probes
only red colored cells and doesn't
notice that we're in the blue case and I
claim this it can be at most two times
Epsilon and the proof is just look at
any point or function input that's
consistent with this blue red input so
I've got a one output so there is some
special column there is a unique special
cell the map from blue red to this is
that special cell is blue and etc etc so
take any input that's one input for
pointer function that's consistent with
that X and then I'm gonna create another
Z prime which just flip the value of
this special cell so one of these is
that no input one of these is a yes
input the only way or place they're
different is in this special cell and
and our algorithm is supposed to have
abort Delta and error probability
Epsilon so if we don't query this
special cell then we're gonna have too
much error so it's not only the
probability that no blue entries are
carried is to probability that this
special entry isn't queried this at most
two times Epsilon
okay so the reduction from pointer
function to encoding function we already
did at the beginning that was a generic
application in this query resistant code
so that actually completes our chain of
reductions which shows a lower bound for
the encoding function okay we have three
minutes left I'm gonna skip the strong
direct sum theorem because I think it's
gonna take approximately six minutes but
y'all almost all of you have done direct
sum like this is all just one big
technical Markoff argument I think it's
gonna be more useful to talk about open
problems so as I think I mentioned
already just this is new research we
haven't submitted it yet neither one of
us work right complexity experts when we
started this so I think there are a lot
of questions that I find interesting so
the I think the biggest drawback to this
query resistant cold right now
this is a construction that we have
blows up the length or the size of the
code by an exponential factor so our
strong direct sum ends up working as
long as epsilon is not smaller than like
inverse quasi polynomial which is pretty
good
but I think you should have a scaling
with epsilon that goes all the way down
to exponentially small error the only
thing that's holding us back right now
is the inefficiency of this query
resistant code and I think our
construction actually is a lot stronger
than we need so maybe there's a more
efficient code we have one function
that's robust to aborts and you gonna be
interesting to characterize which
functions that are robust to aborts and
I think the most interesting next
direction for me is this strong direct
sum for compose functions which maybe
not the strong dark some part but the
compose function story we'll talk about
in 30 seconds
[Applause]
this is query complexity with reports
I'm not familiar with the kurenai's
paper the specific one you're talking
about so that would be good for me to
become more familiar it's just a like
the zero error or zero communication
yeah that's a good question
so so just to sum up for everyone so
Jeremy's talking about communication
complexity paper which also uses aborts
and I haven't thought about that
connection the work from communication
complexity that I'm most familiar with
it talks about aborts is this strong
direct sum that Gregory and David and
Marko Montano did and and they're this
strong direct sum theorem is
conceptually very similar we tried it
here I'll just do this one page without
the analysis the idea here is that
because we want to compute FK with
overall error epsilon intuitively
computing each particular entry should
have error roughly epsilon over K so
we're gonna compute some function f on
one coordinate by embedding
into an appropriate coordinate so the
idea to use aborts here and the high
level conceptual way to do it
is very similar to Gregory's paper I
think the biggest drawback from my
communication complexity perspective
with Gregory's papers the strong direct
Sam works for interactive complexity but
in practice interactive complexity with
aborts and errors for information
complexity like we we don't know how to
use it except for one-way communication
typically yes oh yes we are
thank you
yeah Omega should not be equal equals
Omega
let's take Jess
[Applause]